Joe is no I'm just weird for a good old
from a sea starting stream health that
seems good all right yes that's what I
am getting the notification and we are
laughs welcome to the i loss podcast and
the Lords of gaming dotnet episode
number 139 it is another glorious Sunday
we're back at the roundtable on the
Lord's Day and today we've got to duel
for shut DualShock 4 attachment top 5
games of the decade
top 5 games to discuss his power
situation is to join me in the morning
the solo game hole is for the single
player selfish experience and also the
sastra Thomas mister off my profile
Illuminati and lore patron of the iron
baked mom main Lord sovereign how you
doing sir good morning sir
quite some time stand up everybody stand
up in the room we got that round you
know
do yourselves a favor listen to the
audio I pick not cooperating with the
lights but oh yeah please listen to our
takes on Star Wars the rise of Skywalker
total spoiler casts and then we
definitely gave some thoughts on the
movie definitely check that out but yeah
man I'm telling I'm telling a little bit
under the weather didn't play any games
this week I'm so mad at myself I wanted
really wanted to play play tail but
hopefully this coming week especially
Christmas day after all the festivities
I will sit down and play some games like
wait like game pass and everything like
remember I like it used to be Christmas
a Leo black like I don't know I found
myself not Peter because I feel like
damn I got everything or saying spoil
Christmas for a lot of dude honestly
like I stopped I stopped it I said my
collection is literally a collection now
like it's if if I had physical copies of
stuff they'd be collecting dust so it
doesn't make any sense to keep
purchasing stuff at launch unless I'm
super excited to play at launch or
something that we're gonna be talking
about like it just doesn't make any
sense anything just talk about it so I
was thinking about this like when when
when the series X launches in in
November was to me it's gonna be the
first time that I don't bring a console
home with physical media
who didn't who did that for you a
perfect segue to go get that shirt even
at the start of this Jen right there you
know they were touting the digital I
didn't trust them I said I don't know
man I'm gonna come home day one and not
gonna be able to download my games so I
said let me buy physical copies that you
know win it until I bought rise I bought
the rise in three I bought back and
three I've got all of that but you know
everything you know I'm not I'm not
getting any sort of physical media
anything so the Lord wait
aka my four Lords game that netted
severance I seen them in a bit salute
miss is some names up in there so yeah
that's been pretty much it right so just
trying to get back a track at the
holidays then hopefully with the time
off and get your gaming on a little bit
man no doubt and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka
the excess gamer oh the lord of combat
sports king of the statues ninja turtles
fire by the way I got into raw eggs whoa
there's nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement ooh
be loving Lord King how you doing sir
first of all I want to win to wish
everyone a happy winter solstice yes all
that good energy let's bring it back to
the basics baby is the start of a new
years about to happen and oh oh yes
that's actually set out to stitch 66 69
with a $5 super chat that is why I think
Series X will have a version with no
disc drive multiple who did that for you
emojis five all right so um first of all
let's get to that combat talk real quick
oh boy did you catch that combat talk
all those combat Ian's let's get to that
kind of that so let's talk about it baby
all right so we had Jacobs vs. Chavez Jr
and what what I want to say is boxing is
not like football or baseball
you don't play boxing yep you know
that's the do or die sport it's a blood
sport it's blood guts and tears and my
heart goes out to Cesar Chavez Jr if
people don't know
on Saturday he got you know he had a
fight with Danny Jacobs leading up to
the fight Chavez didn't want to take a
drug test going into the fight he didn't
make weight he had to give up a million
dollars of his purse to Danny Jacobs and
Danny Jacobs still took the fight that
man came into that ring no less than 192
193 and Danny Jacobs came in at 171 um
so he outweighed the man probably about
20 pounds maybe maybe about 30 pounds
non-speech about it yeah he was a huge
boy um at the beginning of the fight and
towards the end of the fight
um but then he Jacobs understood what
was needed to be done he signed and he
knew that this was the biggest draw that
he can get and in packed the house it
was ten thousand people there ten
thousand is not a small number of people
ten thousands of a substantial number
those are paying tickets and then you're
not talking about the the the
pay-per-view buys and stuff like that
with his own you know it's a service so
he maximized his dollar he got into the
fight with Chavez Jr during the fight
Chavez Jr was imposing as well a little
bit early because he was the bigger man
Danny had to get acclimated to the
weight and once Danny got acclimated to
the weight you saw the hand the muscle
memory Danny looked the best I've ever
seen him he his body was right his his
mental was right as physical everything
we told her Danny Jacobs the black boy
from home from Brooklyn
oh look I drew heart surgery back Oh
cancer was on his spine
they thought he'd never fight again so
they call him Danny Jacobs the miracle
man
but as he fought him he Hema Shaw has
engaged any cost shoppers at the bridge
of the nose and Chavez went back to the
corner and he quit oh he said uh you
know you couldn't breathe or something
of the nature I thought he had a panic
attack I mean it's not unheard of you
know put the gloves in when you locked
in to something it takes a certain
amount of Zen a certain amount of calm
you have to have a certain of spirit to
climb in those ropes your hands is bound
we normally like to grab stuff as you
know humans so he's in that ring his
hands is bound and he's fighting the man
he's losing the battle and he's no on
substance abuse you know I don't know
what he's doing but you know it's it's
it's in his blood or whatever you know
because his pops you know his pops past
that dirty gene on him and you know he's
in there and he's battling his demons in
and outside the ring all right there and
he's falling apart mm-hmm now instead of
his pops hitting the ropes and getting
up there and hugging his boy cause it
pops quit - we wolf watch them quick
when his pops quit against Oscar De La
Hoya so don't act like sir like you
didn't have a moment with your hair got
split you quit - you want no more that's
smoke when I try to quit again Sweet Pea
when he was beating your brakes off and
he hit too low and he was trying to quit
then or when you had your substance
abuse problems listen man I seen Creed
and it just took me back to that moment
and Creed where he was disappointed with
his son and they had a moment when he
when the moms left down here to hold the
boy yeah um my heart goes out to him
because he's battling so much and I
really hope he gets the help that he
needs because you know it's so much
pressure on that kid came in the rig was
cry like this I like a saga
it is like the
Ark of this kid's career like he always
he could never live up to the legacy of
his father
what is he tried and and that's a you
know how that haunted him that's haunted
him and then to the point where he's you
know it to it to his own he's he's
contributed his own undoing just because
as a result of that he's not the type of
person that's oh it's pushed to go above
and beyond it he can do it for a little
bit but he can't sustain it mm-hmm and
then it just it's also overall it's
become a burden during his entire life
where he just can't get out of that
shadow and feel to divert I just think
it's a mistake for um like it's like
being Michael Jordan and LeBron so yeah
right it's a mistake for you to go into
your father's foot like stay your father
is the goat at what he did you always
gonna be compared to don't you think as
a child as a son you want to emulate you
I think when you're younger you want to
emulate but it comes a point your skill
I mean there's those rare cases where
you know it's where there was a great
father with drink you know I will say
like Steph Curry's and exact like hit he
became greater than his father is Steph
Curry father was not nice like that
Corner three sweet but he was well but
he was but you're right he wasn't the
superstore like that's one of the rare
instances where I see the Sun just
surpassed you know I'm saying right but
you're the most part I know I've never
seen a superstar like a gold level
player or athlete have you know and I'm
saying like a son that is like okay you
know I'm saying I've never seen yeah
it's too much you've had yeah you've had
good players and have superstar sons I
got you know right dizzy copy well he
said Griffin graffiti I was about to say
that and actually I could a good senior
was not go it wasn't level you are we
trying to we're not saying good players
they have great kids
we're talking about great players I'm
talking about them had them going yeah
you know no your kids not gonna surpass
the national as we did real quick let me
get to the noise
finally winter solstice means a little
over four hours of light per day here
hashtag bring back the Sun keep up the
great work and Happy Holidays salute
lordy I believe that my Canadian brother
out there what's the temperature put the
temperature temperature is always crazy
[Music]
so I need to know what's happening all
right so I said no again let's get to
the uplifting fight let's get up to that
fight though let's go to that uplift and
fight let's get up to that charlo
Harrison - OH
so the first fight right I thought uh
Harrison got away with you know when he
won he you know he look like a bank
robber yeah everything but the mask oh
hey it was so good
so leading up today he's trying to get
that run back right so he's supposed to
fight in June so Tony Harrison in his
little mind he thought okay if I fake an
injury right they go oh he's gonna fight
he's gonna have that day and he's not
gonna be ready to fight and then I'm
gonna get a fight in and then you know
then I get had to run back no what
happened was charlo fought on the day
that they were supposed to fight not to
do clean-out mm-hmm and they they held
Tony back to fight you gotta had to
fight shuttle so yo if he didn't sound
like Ken shout out the kentang like
change so bad
yo you know what to do running his mouth
you know he's nice but he ain't great
yeah you know my office night yeah he
want his mouth to scare you Charlo and i
said okay so they got to the weigh-in at
the weigh-in and they talking to each
other like Tony swag this hand yeah so
what I saw was I saw Tony trying to get
out of the fight alright sounds like ah
you think if you smack your hand he's
gonna swing on you and then you like I
can't tell fight that you know so they
gave each other a hug and then they got
to the ring now is when you in the ring
second round
caught him on the bridge of the nose try
to break his forehead open has a good
accountability to this sovereign
understand telling me Tony was kind of
working him a little bit there it's like
he won't come up with that knock down
like he was really combat talk I was
running around off I said it was gonna
be a TKO he proceeded to put them hits
on we're hitting them with them thirteen
punches I love the way his head was
snapping back so he just head back so
good that at the end of the fight Tony
just stood there with the towel on his
head with his mouth all crew if he had
no rap about that cholo got his belt
back it is in the bushes
real quick Bob I know he go along to
combat frankly the Korean Zombie just
absolutely destroyed Frank yeah I love
Frankie but Frankie's taking a lot of
history and you can tell like like your
chin is just not the same yeah and
Korean Zombie just absolutely demolished
I think I think the decline for me was
the Ortega fight I did yeah after that
it's like you just been in too many wars
too many wars against guys that are bad
guy he's always a little engine that
could where's nota Frankie man I mean
like I said at the end of the day still
a legend you know me alone in the
building
I want Bellator you know circular young
and upcoming it is Bellator all about
the bare naked truth
I'm school and three bare naked choke
and it was wrong
one little dude he i'ma call him the
rabbit Wolverine because that you was
the most savage little dude I've ever
seen like he jumped at him with both
hands in the air
yeah this is how he be to do right he
jumped on his head and spun around his
back so oh dude no he was going for the
rear naked choke so you know normally
you throw yourself forward to crash into
the guy right he get a front tuck to
make the to land on the little guy's
head so he knocked a little guy out I
didn't care about that I see you I said
I gotta find out who these dudes are and
watch bullets so I'm all about it now
you gotta grab you a selection of weak
oh so check it out right so yesterday
upgraded my son for the winter solstice
he got game passed he's in his xbox one
so he's he's he gave me the greatest hug
that a father can forget he's into the
ecosystem now so he was just downloading
games and playing games and just losing
his mind and in his xbox love right now
with all the past loves oh yeah I know
games and I see muted come into the
realm Lord of the stream team himself
Lord penis Naldo himself roundtables
host what's going on man what's going on
how are you what's good I had a intense
week man so I started you know stopped
in with you guys and spend this last
last Sunday with you here - we got the
og oh you got you know one of the ones
that put the brick in the dirt Oh G
hunters with the green
this is Mike good we gotta get it's like
the call he's still working and he's
still working he's still work we go go
go get up - trying to get the motorway
repeating what you were playing man I
crazy week I did as per usual some of
the division hardcore this week only
person not bring anything did that do
the bunch of escape from tarkov
I did I placed my gtfo last night with -
and it was yeah yeah he's me up at like
1:30 at 9:00 is like hey I got a we need
a fourth you want in I'm like yeah my
wife is gonna kill me but okay I'll do
it
there's a lot of fun begin to lowered an
attack I got shot do what you want to do
yeah okay that was the saddest thing I
read this we himself the shinobi lore
Cognito spread never listen to rum and
IOP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so for me
it has been out of worlds out of worlds
in outer world oh love it it just I just
doing all these side quests I'm just I'm
chilling how many of you but right now I
watched a few but right now I'm liking
the UM the priest knew he is hilarious
yeah that's my victim and then uh what's
a perv on TV whatever I body though cuz
they're so diametrically opposed like
she is miss wholesome and you know
butterflies and rainbows and he's like
we got to we got to do we got to do we
got a mess with disc Errol company and
he is not the priest like he his
preaching is out the window
did you go to his little side I did a
stay in prison
you howdy where do you learn how to hack
as well as he does Bible verse your
vicar is the most shady reverie to have
see you I love that character better so
definitely definitely we're rocking that
do it actually all that crowd a lot to
love my work so I'm getting a lot of
progress done and stuff like that
so that's a rockin and of course that
there's me you know season is doing the
rightfully should have won best live
service game no no thanks to my website
I got I'm loving the fact that the
storyline with saint-14
and how they how they tricked it to fix
yes and it's it's crazy I don't want to
spoil anything to a lot of people that's
you know didn't purchase shadow or
looking to purchase but there's so much
content and right now I'm 10 overload
man and there's so many tears that the
last thing I say we're talking about on
the last word before he bought his forte
was they're all Friday it was cool is
that we knew it was going to look Scully
bro see he got on the 'black who do we
call you
doing the rubbery I got you we're
getting away with it seriously
everything good the power you doing it
just turned back on I don't know what
they were doing around here money came
playing a lot of Phoenix power point I
kind of like got obsessed with The
Witcher TV show so finish that I mean
I'm halfway through my cable if you're
finished at our energies in a game in a
week
and you guys surprised I took seven
hours out of my tie to watch this
playing around with the wrongdoings it
went without oh no no I I was working I
just I didn't play I didn't play too
much games I literally dedicated all the
time to that and what's funny is like
after that that lost in space show came
up and I was too lazy to find the
controller I ended up watching three
episodes you like in a Lawson space
right now yeah it's so far it's okay I'm
only like two to Nattie episodes in all
right I'm thinking about me you an
income and doing this show together talk
you watching for the week being that you
want to blaze eyeballs through stuff we
can definitely talk about which I don't
I'm not really plays TV shows that much
like I'm lays a lot of animes but that's
what that's what I like about Netflix
because like this Disney Plus thing I
got a wait like two months to water you
in people's like oh you know Netflix
you'll blaze and it'll be over okay so I
blaze you know that the
the usual butcher and then I think
Tuesday's season 2 of Lawson space comes
out and then next week that Y show comes
on so let's not act like that Netflix
only makes one TV show okay we're done
like we got too much stuff up this or
they need to put a cap on yeah good and
they're like that's a week away so stuff
like that but King on what they allude
to what you talking about so real quick
and I'm saying oh definitely special
announcement we want to send you know
some positive thoughts to our LP gaming
brothers you know anytime you guys in
the room we consider you guys family
so if stuff is going on with you guys
you know we don't put your complete
business out but at the end of the day
you know we want to let people know
you're people going through stuff man so
salute to my brother and I'm saying and
cat daddy fat stacks he's going through
it right now you know I'm saying you
know why for your situations we got a
bunch of other Lords going through some
stuff right now bill still well a lot of
crazy one Lord tipsy a lot of people who
have lost you know someone or something
close to them
so again if you see these guys on
Twitter please so some positive vibes
you know saying is always appreciated
you don't know how many people are
suffering in silence so definitely want
to get that out there because you guys
in the room you guys a family so much
love to that and King I think actually
saw if you want to get that I believe
it's JD
me and Kidd were talking about that like
apparently netflix has han solo for like
a year exclusivity I'm like so you need
to tell me that Netflix is like you
can't have your own [ __ ] like that just
blows my mind it's like Netflix is
literally let not let Disney have their
own agreement yes I'm a promoter - we'll
put our commercial saying the only place
you can see Han Solo so that's what he
said Disney trick them JD game they say
they have more movies on it you can't
that's crazy
let me put the fraud alert on my man
went away cuz you called me and then I
call you back and I get the dial tone
y'all have yeah my brother's podcast is
fire no doubt you already know get into
this poll that happened last week so the
poems also any people have spoken to the
question with the recent reveal
announcement of the Xbox series X at the
game awards do you think this was the
right move by Microsoft to reveal the
console details now ahead of the PS 5
the winner of the three-way ILP poll
with a resounding 70% of the vote was
the yes perfect call excited the base
and show renewed confidence in the brand
group come in at second at only 19% was
the way too soon sony playstation 5 has
ample time to counter group and coming
in that last place with a surprising 10%
was i don't care it still look like the
sex box to me oh those who voted
let's just say we write on is King is in
the building already energy circulating
so I'll set him up real quick so yeah
man so he made an announcement
obviously the DualShock 4 back button
attachment shout out to my boy
Lord wait hey who was in the chat mock
mood one of the writers for Lords gaming
dinette you can check out this fine
piece he has all the DualShock for it
yeah Manus take us out man so pretty
much it is a back attachment for play
said ok for the PlayStation 4 Dual Shock
controller you know I'm saying giving
you some haptic feedback also you can
nap 16 different arm functions to the
two paddles in the back it has an old
light screen you know I'm saying so
giving them a little bit you know
functionality you know some of the
reviews were mixed you know say a lot of
people have things to say you know say
the comments what it look like and other
things but we are going to bring this to
the realm whether what king you could
jump you all if you want to wait let me
know yes I wanna jump though all right
this is your topic the one that I never
opened because I don't have nobody else
to play with
oh this controller I could put the plug
on you will put the pacifier for the
issue did you have actually a lot of
people I want to see I want to see the
sales numbers
pacifier because nobody called for the
pacifier who needs to buy a back button
okay this is what happened right right
so Jim Ryan took a trip down to China
right he went down to he went down to
Foxconn and was like yo what up y'all
was gone we will be here getting ready
make this PS 5 but he's like Oh word PS
5 put up with them Vedas over there
though what do you mean you can't do
this no more yeah but what up put them
on LEDs what we're gonna do with them
all is so that you guys have any ideas
for these OLED screen and they're always
lit from the back of the assembly line
you have carbon to come out from the
back well sir I have an idea we use the
old air screens are you saying we can
use the OLED screen so like replace that
wack touchpad in the front of the green
no no nothing that obvious how about we
take the most advanced display
technology in the world right now a
little circular piece of it and stick it
on the back of the controller yes and
nasty Genesis from obviously we see this
so clearly your feeling is there is no
market for this who's asking this is
where you're at with this it was gonna
clarify your position sir all I'm saying
is that is the one thing I see people
talk about on the on the the elite
controller is yeah by a scuf controller
certain controllers for a long time I
come with all those little back button
but if it work if it's efficient and
works well why does it matter well you
know what it is it's the fact that we
was waiting for this rebuttal so it's
like we know that Sony we
that Sony can't make anything so they
could have make an elite controller no
we're so so the next best thing
no the cake is talk about the rebuttal
to the Xbox series extra take over with
drop man the takeover was drop we
sitting here waiting for ether and any
drops out there Carmen show me the place
three to five or go home don't show
nothing don't come here we know little
pacify you I would say that that's good
you carried over to next gen do you
think that do you think that it's a good
chance since they're doing that they're
not gonna make their own elite
controller now though because I and I
agree with military for what they said
they're saying why would you die why
it's not being cheap make a first party
pro controller a lot of people you know
the scuff is great but I'm sure the
PlayStation faith will want one from
PlayStation they want do you think
they're good do you think they're doing
this so that you can take your ps4
controllers and play it on your PS 5 if
you do that I think it's already been
confirmed that the accessories carry
over so if you'd end up doing that they
can cut the price on the PS 5 a little
bit what do you mean I could like sell
it without a controller well yes do that
do that new system with no control I
think if I have a ps4 I'm gonna pick up
a PS 5 and I get an if I can get a
control if I can get a ps5 that's like
you know 50 60 bucks less and I don't
get a controller and I could use my ps4
I'd use it butthole okay what I think I
think I think it's assumed yeah that
either you absorb the price of that
controller in that initial packaging or
it's part of it like you usually you
don't give you don't you don't sell
yourself you know how crazy it would be
that's like like to explain
now you need a bike controller - ma'am
well what do you mean I need my
controller it doesn't come with the
controller do you mean that extra no I
mean one entirely would be funny that
you know would even be more funny the
fanboys defending that like what what I
do think is if you saw any fans don't go
out and purchase this pacifier so if you
don't then I think that dictates how
they go forward with the controller are
they gonna use the buttons are not is it
what type of controller you might get
with the PlayStation 5 I think that's
gonna be held up with the sales figures
of this because if it's warranted if it
sells enough let's say it sells at least
two to three million right let's just
say some outrageous number then Sony
sees the market that people want this
may be might be the last I was about to
say that they testing the waters ideally
confined space cuz they really have a
minute let's get these super chests I'll
get dirty dr mattock you'll get JD I got
dirty D says so in sold you a castle
with no power chords so I know I know
that I know that was an didn't wanna in
Tendo handhelds came with no extra 30s
they came here no power cord attic get
arm JD gamers her if you can alright let
me find it JD gated with the generous
$20 super shadow I want the old
Microsoft I want them playing dirty I
want them showing a new mature single
play exclusive at every event I want
them showing so many good games at PS
fence PS pass out from no new narrative
disease no I do anything
no a mercy would help blade type stuff
from now on all day every day
that's a kak he wants to name for the
jugular his petty there was an Xbox for
no dis
[Laughter]
[Music]
is it called the pacifier for you I mean
no I don't I don't know who this is for
I don't know that sir but um you know
the functionality the programming will
pad that what is cool um to me soft
don't you think like this might be like
a prelude to the PS 5 controller design
well yeah I think so obviously right
it's a prelude to I'm what I'm assuming
and hoping is changes they've made to
the design but from everything we've
seen like we did see a little bit of
what people assume is the PS 5
controller with the dev kits and it
looked largely the same and they weren't
any other differentiating factors so
maybe they holding that close to the
chest telling you if this works
efficiently and it works good people
want this there's a there's a market
visit how many people have I seen talk
about an elite controller like and
that's literally the the highlight of
the entire controller backpedal like
yeah it was very bad price product is
there a market for this elite controller
and then they did well I mean look
they're like look we ain't gonna spend
the money to make all of that what do
you think the back pedals I think more
for like competitive gamers I don't even
competitive gamers you see that's what I
see that's what me and you and agree
with oh no a lot of competitive gamers
using a lot of them do i they use the
powers my only issue is to me this is
still the one foot in because for me if
you're gonna do the competitor joint the
many different is the hair trigger you
see like this the precipice and then and
then like this half hour press so that
to me gives you the advantage when
you're doing your FPS you doing all that
stuff because you actually are shooting
faster so I want them to have that and
the customizable analog so you get rid
of the dead spots and all that that's
when you go or so I like to start but
they got it do you think this is a
financial thing like financially they
weren't able to commit to a pro
controller
I think I think they could easily
research a developer controller it's
just that's not their priority they're
like look like we'll give you that the
biggest feature because like you guys
don't do a lot but you know I watch a
lot of MLB for emoji on on Twitch and
stuff and like they use those hair
triggers and they in those backpedals
they'll put like a grenade or something
attached to them like a lot of people
use those back pedals yeah yeah I think
the PS faithful want people like they
don't like the alternating uh the
alternating uh analogs right and the
stuff is kind of built like an xbox
controller so I would think they want
one from Sony it doesn't make any sense
that they wouldn't and just sort of they
would they technically partnered up with
stuff to make that controller like that
an integrity there's made by another
entity but they didn't go with their
design which is weird right it's like
they acknowledge that the other design
pure design what controller best for
first for first-person shooters that is
not the PlayStation control is really
not all that suited for first-person
shooters and especially like what is it
like combat what is it that Elite Pro
Series by the game you know competitive
stuff so and I see those guys take out
their own special controllers like they
pros they scuff that Nikon one um you
know really nice controllers I was gonna
get a really nice controller and I like
[ __ ] except I don't I don't like this
half in half out yeah if you want to do
it do it but is it a financial thing
because when you all would take these
stuff you have to get to manufacturing
your to design research and development
you got to do all this stuff right and
then you have to go and test it and then
once you have to get it out so did they
want to just say hey listen let's give
them this yes see how this sells and if
it sells properly this is the the least
common denominator that we can get out
to see that's the vibe I'm getting I
feel yeah I think in just to see the
waters if there's a tremendous
demand then maybe that emboldened to
people who want the elite controller
behind the scenes to say okay look our
base is buying this you know I'm saying
and maybe we're gonna get I think I
think right I mean they're super jet
dirty D shoutouts to read the super
shades one o'clock dude you had no cord
in the box or am I crazy
JD gamer would like to see Microsoft add
two standard buttons at the end the day
I don't you think this is necessarily
like a financial thing I don't this the
scuf controller could sell like crazy
and I don't think they're gonna make
their own so they I think I feel they
made this that's my quick line what do
you think was the thought process when
they just solidly just saw the easy cash
out but do you think that they sat there
with metrics and said the like someone
had to convince this in front of a board
right and say look we're gonna put this
a like what do you think was the pitch
like to the boilie controller ad was
those backpedals so they're like let's
just make an add-on for the current
controller we currently at because
there's there's really if they were if
they're there - the biggest thing for
Ally controller dough use on those elite
controls too many things that week your
controller any way that you like and I
get him in my work my controller pause
but you know you gotta really you can't
really say the back buttons is the main
feature no they have a feature of back
buttons but I put elevated and I put the
round tips at the end pause and you're
so it's not it's not like how you saying
it like oh the back buttons is daily
controller no it's way too complicated
just for that that's not it won't be
summed up that small note a little back
button that's something that's some
throwaway crap that they threw in there
for some AG buttons I think the
PlayStation fan deserves a pro
controller next one done to have one in
that official space let me just ask
people like what did you think was the
sales page be like where you at with
with like kind of testing the water or
where you at with this I I think I think
there was a bunch of different things I
think that yes there were testing the
waters yes I think they're trying to
give people I really think that with the
the series X coming out and I'm
announcing it
I think PlayStation is at the point now
where they're like alright well we're
gonna have to figure out where we could
save some money because I think they're
gonna have to drop the price like you
guys are saying down so that they can
eliminate the lesser of the two options
which would be the the what's called the
anaconda so I think that they're they're
trying to figure out a way to cut some
costs in doing this will give them that
so the people are trying to make the PS
5 cheaper so you still think they're
gonna take the controller
I don't know if they're gonna do that or
they're gonna try to prevent people from
buying second master race I think you
talk to a guy that is that for Christmas
after Christmas I'm ordering myself foot
pedals because I need for first-person
shooter games so you're talking to a guy
that goes over the top when it comes to
games yeah yeah so it's not professional
if you're gonna peek around the corner
right so I don't have to hit a and then
D at the same time I can use my feet cuz
they're on the floor so I can use my I
can use it to strafe with the a with my
left foot and then I can peek around a
corner you and Papa guy so that's that's
why I'm getting foot publicity listen
all this you--you'll by these foot
pedals to still get clap when you come
around that career
and don't get no controller you know he
wants them to pay 600 the same prices
above the back the pacifier yeah by the
way we cop with cog texted me and I
thought he actually mistyped me that
that topic subject line what do you hear
when he said it to me and I googled it
and now my whole entire Google she said
they need it to show something
PlayStation 5 not the PS 5 is a hundred
percent ready to come out go with that
we do this we'll be doing we really now
we so gassed everybody this is the first
time I've seen Sony not respond to good
news in the chat please come out with
the Box system first and not on my watch
what's up guys Preston like mute and
unmute cuz the TV's behind me so I don't
want to tenderfeet apocatip see the chat
but we shut you out for your loss good
to see you brother you know bottom yeah
man so yeah Katie will move there thank
you sir yeah we got that with the with
the controller join our lab but Oh
school move on you know I'm saying so Oh
Lord oh man you got a juicy one you kind
of
I'll say they split it up into two cuz
you you you wanna do kind of like the
the top five games of the decade are
what people think feel is are their top
five or the top five games of the decade
objectively right now necessarily your
favorites all right right in the second
point let me do the second part of UJ
which is the top five personal to
personal
kukuku like your personal file you okay
with nobody feel like that sorry
let's start it off my personal is my if
I say scars my all-time favorite game
that's fact
what you just said to so this is great
topic you own it
what is the five objective games of the
decade let's go
that one little caveat to this I now
that you know it doesn't have to be
objectively what you feel the top five
best on I did influential yeah so for
influential first I gotta come I gotta
say minecraft you own it so yeah I mean
I'm never playing minecraft today in my
life and I don't intend to but like it's
it's a game that appeals to all ages in
a way that a lot of games just don't
right you can't and it's the it's like
it's a game it's a it's like a blank
slate like you could you can build
whatever you want in Minecraft and the
fact that now it's kind of ubiquitous
across every platform imaginable it
changed it changed the way people play
that like you didn't that's not a game
you only play on a PC that's not a game
you're only playing on a console is that
game you're playing it on the phone
you're playing on a tablet oh you know
my niece and nephew play it wherever
they get the hands on minecraft they're
playing that game so I think it just
sort of began
to change the idea of what a singular
game can do across the entire landscape
of gaming you don't mind one inch all
around because this way we don't steal
each other because you probably won't
have everybody's USAA
so add it give me one of the influential
five for you of the generation or most
impactful field I think one of the most
impactful games in history is fortnight
that game literally came out it says
Sony I don't care how big you are you
folding came out this is oak seam I
don't care how big you are you folding I
got Steve working with people they don't
normally work with EA Microsoft its it's
got Sony voting on cross play they're
probably this is so reason that cross
playing cross progression is gonna be
next gen mm-hmm
like I don't think there's a game bigger
than that I really don't like maybe call
the duty because they call the Judean
halo because they've involved like the
overall first-person-shooter marketing
but like as far as like impactful I
don't see anything beating that because
now we're gonna have cross playing cross
progression and if I if you if you were
to ask me that a couple years ago I said
there's no way no way Papa Sony got at
the e3 where at when they were like left
out as the only player at the time that
wasn't supported if you think about it
for tonight's big enough were sony's
like we ain't doing that and then you
know before you know what epic cent will
you ain't being part of the boys club
like we ain't even let you do this you
could be over there and you're a little
singular closet because we gonna have we
have a party out here and you're just
gonna be in there like they didn't they
didn't folder Sony they didn't state it
ok Sony doesn't want to do it let's not
do it and because of them Bungie did the
same thing like a year later they're
like oh you don't want to do what
everyone else is doing a but you yeah we
could we could say that they set the
cross plate keep a train they they
showed everybody look so nice that they
pushovers all right like what sapphire
the big bags all the stuff that gate was
there
big man as its what it was King man he
wanted your Winchell kids gone King okay
I hear me now oh there we go okay I was
in a building or a final I'm gonna say
pop G of G is because the battle royal
craze is because of of G winner winner
chicken dinner
hepatitis yeah without pop G I highly
doubt fortnight a fortnight was a
totally different game just a PvE school
youth was that you know that the battle
royal some some free stuff extra be paid
for the real game for on fortnight but
pug G has a feel to it um it has like
before y'all was getting a lot of
references from Phil Dominus Maximus
Spencer on from me talking about he
landed a bit cheeky with a butter knife
if you ain't pop G nobody goes to
p'chenk Els you that do it's it has a
feeling it made me feel like how first
played Mario but you know when you when
you play some game like and you first
play Castlevania feeling of the game it
has it and not all games get this film
it's like you know once in a little
generation a game of come across and
you're in such a way pause like
everybody get that you definitely had a
positive F word
No alright so but I saw it was a
phenomena yeah and I won it like pub G
made me want to know what is this battle
royal why are people going crazy and
then when you played you like I get it I
get it man like that tension with the
final journal in Russian yes especially
if the circle goes on one building you
need know there's like at least the team
in there and you're just and they got a
jump and you just sitting it's just I
felt that in his body shoot him in a
know many will know that we are you
doing a lot of slang done by the
competitor pub she was so good it's so
well-being at work artists regardless
for pub he is today
Kings right if it wasn't for pub
everything we got
let's get my man Louis who have arrived
I need one of your five he's got the
let's see one influential game for me
this generation off the top of my head
Monster Hunter world and the big reason
for that is because Capcom with that one
game
showed if you care about a game you put
time into it and invest in it you can
make a game that's not typically on
platforms usually handheld and mobile
and make it this big success by just
making it a good game and I think there
needs to be more examples of that
because I mean nowadays we get plenty of
games that aren't finished or feel empty
or lackluster they try to piece new
stuff afterward and Maus 100 didn't do
that it came out as a complete game with
lots of content with a with a very
expansive world that felt alive granted
whenever released I had a whole bunch of
issues especially a multiplayer in
connection and whatnot but they fix that
that's what it did yeah it had an impact
they really didn't absolutely oh shout
out to Vogel's Creek
he says King David we had some great
times planned pubs you to get monkey
punch hot monkey love it and Lord of it
five destinies and others he taking it
back as the funky gang at that point he
knows how many hours we sat then we put
in and how many times monkey punch shot
me in the back of the head probably
something you never expected are you
talking about the if you say the Destiny
killer division and my first-person
shooter it's actually they did two
things which I thought was very very
interesting for the this past decade the
Assassin's Creed series because they won
introduced open-world because they had
that because they they had the first
real open-world experience with black
flag and then the other thing they did
was they reinvented the genre MS Jean
rrah and it still stayed alive because
that changeover that they did from that
the unity series and then they went into
the the Egypt version origins that was
something that I think a lot of the
people that were fans of it like myself
didn't expect to keep alive and they did
which I thought was very interesting and
having that open world Skyrim wouldn't
be around if it wasn't for open world
was loading times with all those what
did you say if it wasn't for wouldn't be
a Skyrim wouldn't have been around Black
Flag you throw up me we talk about dizzy
I'm talking to you Black Flag is out
before Skyrim there bud and Mauro it was
a before Skyrim but that was an open
world it had loading zones oh can I have
some into the bushes for sky 2011 and
alright so okay alright no sorry 2013
let's let's calm down welcome back off
the ledge
[Laughter]
she's already fallen listen token this
is his most influential game come out
for him till next year for me this year
so relax for you know but I'm not going
to I will surprise you
I'm a surprise now going in who doesn't
need for going not good I can easily
pull that card for all
I'm actually better cuz I'm gonna pull
that card I'm you got it which it three
which it three change the game
you know which agree I agree with that
character that base and because the
Witcher we while we just say to Witcher
and because The Witcher we might be
seeing no when I have to say what you're
three Witcher 3 is probably the only
reason we're gonna start getting decent
TV shows of gaming related stuff going
here on out one there's no Witcher 3 the
reason I'm saying what's your three it's
cuz what's your three took everything
the other ones dead and they said that's
not good enough we're doing more petty
said we all know every game done copy
rise so the role you need to stop which
III just a side quest alone the the
richness of the story with and the DLCs
that let's be real city project right I
don't hate giving them for free but
these are just quality bangers do you
know DLCs and it been on every platform
including I think what your three is one
of the most relevant games because we're
gonna get it's pretty much wasted in
that genre
you had people you had people like
Bethesda that was getting comfortable
making the guys because the games like
The Witcher they're looking at that kind
of games like yo we need to improve man
which I didn't watch the TV show The
Witcher definitely TV shows good
like I enjoy you know I probably put
like 20 25 to 30 hours on The Witcher
and what's funny is like I've never even
scratched the surface to that game like
I always put a bunch of hours in that
game like every like once a year and
then like I end up not being played for
like two months and I have to drop it
again and I have 350 hours and I don't I
don't I don't think I'm out of the first
area you know what's your fan like that
now I have to give it to it like oh god
I don't want nothing of that sort in my
life you did remember it came out like
in April yeah in fallout came out later
hmm
all out look like straight trash in
comparison this is true really
so when cog says that it changed the
game pretty much took but there's
there's like look this is what you used
to do this is what we do good morning
and salute iron Lords panel let's bring
it back to solve mega give us another
one
and for another one hmm I have to go hmm
I think I'm gonna go with The Walking
Dead Season one mmm
season gonna be yeah dad kind of
single-handedly brought back the
adventure game back in the day King
knows you know David tentacle Grim
Fandango the old LucasArts games loved
those games but they needed to bring
that forward if they were gonna do it in
a way that was appealing to more people
without the weird puzzles and stuff like
that cuz it has some really weird
some nonsensical stuff in those games in
terms of gameplay so what Walking Dead
did was focus on the narrative part of
it and make it easy for everybody to
sort of get engaged and you had your
little cute E's and stuff like that but
it was nothing that the average person
couldn't get into and then when you
focus on that story in that relationship
between Clementine and League um and
that ending was it to me it catapulted
it sort of brought that genre right back
and then afterwards you started seeing
obviously for telltale that the story
didn't end very well for telltale
overall there was a lot of over
saturation but it kind of spurned things
like going
home and a fire watch and like obviously
life is strange to me I that was you
know you know you think it's the whole
genre for the telltale games and not
just walking dead no I think the Walking
Dead law and all they were still hot one
of the best games that I've ever played
it was a life is strange and that I I
guarantee you that gay never would agree
and within and within telltale like a
lot of people feel that the wolf among
us is dude from dizzy he said
objectively gta5 has to be on that list
everything they done with online and
sales staying in the top five from last
June through 2019 or play that's it's a
and I'll put another thing with GTA 5
they literally spawn this
microtransaction Bulls up we wouldn't be
dealing with out this microtransaction
can't give me one no I'm gonna have to
go a world of warcraft the reason why
I'm gonna go with World of Warcraft
that's the granddaddy of them all
anybody who sits a you still waiting for
World of Warcraft on your xbox or your
PlayStation every every wait for this to
come up and show up so we could just say
it's on listen I lost when you know what
I know a game is really hit their stride
but I'm playing when I'm spending real
like cash dude I was at Western Union
Western Union in a guy some money so he
can give me gold in the game I was
sending cash off to some dude I had no
idea if I was really sending money I
listen I had a relationship yes with
individual I don't know if was a male or
female or what though we had a online
marriage
got married in the temple make me
clothes listen I had shut my PC off you
know what I turned into the do with the
door windows and I will go get my kids
from school and place them in a room
let's see you're good you got your stuff
you're ready everything is good hold on
I got a raid I gotta do is probably the
most detrimental that everybody that
touched that game has went through this
and had to get the winter rolls I don't
want the game back but I'm gonna tell
you that game is the most influential
game that I have ever touched and I will
never touch it again drugs you have to
agree the one you have to agree one
thinking about Wow is that you like for
me I have a dream I think about I have
some of my best friends coming from
Warcraft from the years I played with it
yes and I'm - I I'm telling you I got
stories like I was I was a groomsman on
a guy's wedding that I never met Wow
yeah like I'm telling you like I met
people through Wow and experiences
throughout that it's it's I'm speechless
when it comes to thinking about it I
love that game lutely nuts listen I got
more stuff that could say pause you can
do whatever you go to your inbox and
somebody every day gives you some epic
items that they made this self and
nobody else can get these perks on this
items you're gonna wipe that person -
hahaha
right now another one I'm gonna give me
give me Capcom a lot of love because
they've been on fire here lately
and bye
we didn't ask for the top five in our
games Saturday
no what are you they gonna say del Migra
no actually it's actually gonna be the
Resident Evil to Rio I knew he's gonna
say and that is because as somebody who
never actually played the original game
oh I know I know
no no I mean it's so - but like I was so
young I don't even I don't I didn't even
get far exactly right so I played the
remake and it's an amazing game I mean
it's it's very well done it and the
reason I want to say it's influential is
because at least for me personally it's
the epitome of what a remake should be
it they went back you know they I mean I
did my research about it before I played
it obviously I know they went back and
they changed parts of the game and they
improved it and you know many ways and
you know they worked on the AI they
changed story scenes interactions with
characters and whatnot I mean it's it's
a game did all those desert game of the
year I'm with that see that drug I'm
looking raizy though because my main
role for a game of the year when it
comes to video game awards that I have
always said that a remake should never
be Game of the Year
yeah yeah you was with me until you got
that game yeah see I was voting for
Resident Evil though this this time
around I was because I genuinely think
it's just that good well it's just that
bit of a game though will speed it up
just a little bit we got more on PE so I
got to do my second one yeah I thought
you took disease with GTA but GTA
totally try to get three but you
the Dark Soul series yes you would you
would never have like you know sir guru
died twice you never have like a lot of
those amazing new games you know what
you know would have been a blessing for
that though we we wouldn't get that
awful series the surge because the
destiny you go games like the division
like anthem
you got games like dance central second
most influent
holding it down you know say salute I
feel that brother you get that on you
get that you do that you do that and you
know because of games like destiny you
have you know Luke shooter Kings like
like Borderlands developers like saying
yo we got to redefine our stuff like
that's why you have like I think it's
called God hands like they literally are
going away from the borderlands
franchise in the way it functions like
it but they're doing it differently but
you know I do want to give it a quick
you know know of what's a what's the
word you use for when it's someone like
honorable mention like I think overwatch
overwatch yeah oh yeah it started that
whole lane shooter thing this first
version of the hero shooters when the
break that I add on and expound upon
your fantastic choice listen man look I
know a lot of y'all hate this game I get
it you know it's been we know the floors
witty
they hate the game cuz they got Titan
smashed one to me
I'm gonna round game in a long time King
we've seen this I've never seen a game
that has been down and come back and
then and come back and then it's usually
in gaming you die you did I've never
seen of a game polarizing and galvanize
a base so many times even after coming
from the lowest but you know what about
it yeah if you think about it that shows
how good and how bad a developer bunch
it shows how addicting the gameplay is
because think about this every one of us
including myself on this panel have
quick destiny of avoid we're never
coming back
the I'm tired of it and then they do
something and they get it right it's
crazy it's good raising good what it is
is you know there's a shift in the
balance every time a game says they're
the destiny killer they absorb all that
hate when the demon game on the console
spacer that that's what's happening no
matter games come out they're like we
the destiny killer and they call of
duty's it's been through every murderous
role of MMO competition in the console
space you know like five I know bro this
dark but that that's why if you look at
the reaction its art make dizzy go away
from arc and come if you get the
reactions to that to the video game
awards you're the first thing you hear
me say when they announce guard handles
like now don't say that's a destiny
killing about the community you ever
saying again you can say what you want
about the game you cannot talk about
that coming
that community what they do for
charities I'm an Italian boy they got a
whole is Ward's Island they should have
one
mmm oh I mean I should have one on what
you call no soundtrack of war they still
need to win music award one day cuz even
from deci one if you don't even like
that you cannot say man wanted McDonald
them dues and destroy that and then to
this day the music is still fantastic
I think it's a biasness towards the game
to be honest nailed it I know why it
doesn't win they are looking at it
whenever we look at any time a new DLC
from destiny comes out like it's a new
game they're looking at it is destiny to
from 2017 I don't care so they're not
looking at it as a new release even
though you know we have taken King
soundtracks and we have well they need
to do what they need to do is put in the
water for longevity because this game
y'all walked away from I have to stand
in here my god I gotta make to you
what's funny is me Cognito used to get
attacked daily especially because
because everyone bought the division I'm
like I'm buying that trash and I used to
get a Vinick and their God with anthem
yeah these games you can ask Lord you
know I have stood strong with destiny to
the Almighty Spartan guys I don't even
like this tee but could give me proud I
want to add on to the destiny thing
don't real quick ok as their original
hunter my heart lies there
that's for game that's my home and I
think the most influential thing that
doesn't he has done then it come from
the game itself but the decision that
Bungie made to separate and let go the
shackles of Activision and and them
doing that it showed that you don't need
to be attached to this big name to
improve your game keep your community
and make your community happy be
successful it's really nice after diggin
got the bag and I'm winning boy fixed up
they make up and got the hand nails done
this day only don't need the sugar daddy
Bungie be resolved from them sitting
there not a problem solved of anything
but the game has been better come up and
you miss no stop man II went to the
Dominican Republic and fixed a stuff up
and Ally out here with a brand new that
strand quite like that fraud you we
can't we gotta be real here I just wanna
shout out the way and he said I finally
Luda shooters a very therapeutic just
play and getting immersed in the grind
no dice did you just make that stranded
yes at a gray for the influencers I want
to know if anybody's that any
influential that before we move on to
the personal file I mean just a real
quick one and this is something that
I've seen cuz my mother doesn't play any
like never ever right but she is
obsessed with one thing to the point I
actually bought her a tablet for for
Christmas we could play that fresh cream
yeah
dizzi read my mind
candy crush candy crush when you really
talk about microtransactions and and and
just that so there's the other game
responsible for microtransactions there
you go
like I'm gonna be honest my mother uh
she she does not care an iota about any
sort of video game and that woman spends
hours a day playing penny I do have a
quick question go to real quick you know
try to make your statements as short as
possible what's that game that came out
to generation you thought was going to
be all that but turned out what I ought
evolved was going to do something
anything yes I'm gonna say World War Z
shot that gun first off you know there
124 people appreciate everyone coming by
definitely if that like but I want you
guys to put in there what's the most
disappointing game that you had so much
hype going into was disappointing though
I mean I never disputed that I just well
no no like I said I never said it wasn't
I just never believed it was as bad as
people made it out to be I was gonna say
one thing that I found really really
interesting was some of the stuff
Nintendo did put out this year which was
like I know they're gonna make fun of me
but the lab oh that was really out of
the box thinking and also the ring
Believe It Or Rises Ariane the the ring
the ring fit game of ring adventure
whatever it is my brother told me that
holes in my niece have been playing it
non-stop sting is being very
disrespectful
emanuelle yanking fur off a rabbits in
the bookings nobody thank you very much
everybody they'd like to make beer
porridge soup with not color but it's
the new year so I'm gonna give you this
yarn to something with that red you
might want to grab your gun cause when
people tell you to more enjoyable you
know you might be nice a the horse
everywhere it's just if I had a gun to
my head and was like you gonna play one
of these games you won't get killed I
put on death stranding oh you know
listen listen no why do you like a good
way one of those two games I'm not I'm
not package is the no place
I'm glad to tale from beer past testicle
unum is gonna have to be with his going
big boy
I'm appointment that's Jenna I dragged a
delivery mic on the room I'd rather
deliver packages before I play right
dead I'm not being a cowboy yes no just
saying that the ring fit thing because I
never I never experienced nice and my
brother playing it they got the second
badge that's a loaded justice of the
chat we've gone from the actually
support to the sales part so we got the
influential I think will pretty much
everybody nailed it even stuff they I
know yeah I don't necessarily like which
I kept it true you know I'm saying but
on man let me set it off man this one
XCOM I think that was arguably the
greatest RTS I've ever played and I we
used to play from back in the day I
think
XCOM enemy within is uh the the one that
really knocked it off yeah I don't think
without enemy what then we never would
have went on here when I enemy with it
but the war of the chosen that dynamic
and like that game did not care about
your feelings and where you were if you
weren't set up like it made you feel
that you were going against overwhelming
odds if any little scientific
breakthrough you did any little research
you did on time to try to combat and use
the alien tech against you and then when
they put them chosen it was the hardcore
STS game like I know people shot the bat
mister tell me out on the show he quit
the gays like this is to what is
ridiculous he's like Ashley that's calm
you don't need to be this hard off level
one like it's just overwhelming odds it
was your people weren't built right that
assassin was gonna have her
about this think about this PD remember
when we used to get scared with the
alien rulers used to come out right you
had the ruler and it chosen it it you
got a rescue mission you only got eight
times and it was so much you something
you think it's a it's a rescue mission
you like three turns in and then and
then the the assassin or the warlock
shows I'm just like well this dudes dead
yeah if you if you get caught in your in
your your ship goes down and got it from
twenty P DS I tried to beat the game
early and if you try to beat the game
early without killing all the chosen
they're all at the last minute like I
did that I tried one turn to that I was
like whoa I guess I'm gonna beat the
game will kill all of them before I come
back here it was impossible
I loved it how they added the first
expansion that they added or actually
they did was the armors yes and they
added the armors and then they added on
top of that more weaponry and stuff that
stuff remember the saving chain mission
where you had to go yumminess for her
father with the pro-x card and then you
get through and then you got the mech
the Mac yo XCOM not only changed the
game with classes the Templars the the
arm what's the other little robot dudes
and the ones that go sniper got like
they had so many classes skirmish or
discourage it it was just sort of well I
cannot wait for part three we know Jake
Salomon them guys is cooking up it's
probably gonna be cheating but you got a
pity but you say did you like it have
you logged in and seen what they did
with the challenges yes the challenges
are great I love that I love the PC
expansion it's it's great it's time for
ex-con 3 but XCOM
war of the time to war of the chosen is
one of the greatest RTS as I've ever
played like III can't remember that in
the amount of hours I'll put just to
beat that game and it was tremendous oh
that as my personal giant deputy I think
I think I've beaten it about four or
five times and that game I just I can
never stop wanting to play it it's just
like Phoenix point I just want to keep
trying those do he said he can't wait
for Gears idea like I'm hoping Gears tax
fills that role for me
because I think gears is another great I
think Phoenix point can fill that role
for what I said that's the og first one
spiracles that's the Phoenix point
famous point isn't as casual as XCOM
either
ya know like they got like like deep
factions in that game yeah see but like
I say if you RTS God to meet us to go
out to yes
but it's bringing back what you got are
we doing like the person's personality I
think if it wasn't for the the Final
Fantasy games I wouldn't be gaming in
general you know they might be making
all garbage now but you know at least
when they was at their height I played
all of them I still played them all the
only games the only Final Fantasy I've
never beat besides like the random
handhelds that they have is 13 because I
can't I refuse to finish 13 for summary
and what's funny is when it was when it
was made backwards compatible I bought
13 I'm gonna make myself do this play 15
minutes of this I'm done fighting
I'm done I'm not trying lightning like
lightning
we ain't talking about this because I
know is sleep over here on the is the
minority in the Final Fantasy community
why can hey that's what that's my video
game waifu man you can't you don't have
to sit down in that corner with the
other three weirdos that like lightning
I'd rather Skyward Sword be in existence
before light means a win this franchise
I gotta go with the franchise - I gotta
go read it that's it right there
franchise step listen man bushes in the
chat right now Final Fantasy please at
least my games relevant
no wine for Dino hit like a rock and
water a daddy knows rock stars done with
this with this franchise you create
clearly missing
let's hear let's hear what he has to say
that rock stars second little baby
didn't grow up well and the other game
is still holding 14 that SOB get his
balls off he preaching right now
honestly red dead when it came to world
building and creating a time in place
there's no other game where you could
just get lost in the desert
and you see the Sun setting and it's
like you feel like you're there they go
crazy like when it comes to that you
could say what you will about the game
play especially random things at people
because any other game recreating a
world absolutely
come on me with the Red Dead one is
better than red date you know I would
say as it games yes I will go
well I don't I I wouldn't necessarily
disagree with that because I think read
there to where the one is more of a
straight-up game whereas read the two is
straight-up an experience experience
like they they purposely that's when we
had all these arguments about all this
stuff like that I said this is what they
wanted it to feel like for better for
worse they didn't wanna do they're like
crap they wanted you to make this like a
job you mean I got I got a brush I
respected as a game kinda and generally
like just rock star general nobody else
is making a game that even comes this
close I really want to see what it's
good what nobody else is making a game
that comes this close to creating a
world an immersive world I will really
want to see what CD Projekt RED does
with play cyber Punk because I think
it's taking us to the next level but
honestly man I mean you could really do
a lot with this world don't let me go in
on your game like I really was trying to
listen to you two you can get off the
horse you could talk you can murder him
if you want
you know rocks comics another game like
that it's called rent that photo you can
do all that same stuff there too
whatever GTA 6 is gonna take it there
GTA 5 is not quite there Oh beat your
new tech what are you talking I had to
agree a song on this at the end of the
day like I like GTA 5 and I did not
really like read dead but the emerg is
two entirely different times right right
now if you'd ever go on loud but we both
online freud's
still solve this is co got it jumps out
of his seat with Nintendo drops a game
but
prefers these metrosexual like sleeping
[Applause]
yo y'all read dead dude serious about
his name right now and my hope and
expectation is a GTA 6
blows read there two out of water one of
my first and five has to be Zelda
brother well let's go because remember I
came from the Wii U I came from the
downtrod and I came from trying to
convince people to buy looking at me
like I was great I mean it was like
really because like the only ones riding
for this big tablet I was in the
bathroom with the tablet and I was
trying everything with the tablet and
dudes are not listen take your tablet we
we don't care about your tablet I French
so go on into the switch I'm like man
and then they released it in a weird
month what are they doing they don't
care but that Zelda it's a whole
different thing
yeah like is when you got to the physics
of some of the puzzles in the rooms and
you know people's complaining because
they didn't have traditional dungeons I
[ __ ] of a we're doing something
different this is old is completely out
of the box yeah you can climb every I
think that made it nice too because
sometimes I didn't have the stamina all
the way right so I would climb to a
Ledge wait to my energy came back and I
planted an egg and I was playing I was
in places where I shouldn't because when
I get updated monster kill me not meet
we're off the mountain understood there
for seven hours climbing up this
mountain yeah I did their mini ball
thing with
I mean for good portion of probably two
months I started with every amiibo you
hear and I had a table set next week
every seven out they shut me down
because it we used to be you could just
do it eliminate Lee but they said no you
can only use your amiibo every 12 hours
and every I had my alarm set on my
father every 12 hours I will make sure
that I'm next to each one
I was sitting like two hours get all the
ones in get all the free stuff and play
my game so sell the definitely
definitely man preaching switch game
where every weapon breaks it exists for
the fact that Zelda breath for the wild
destroys your rig it destroy every
function of the game and it don't look
nowhere near as pretty and I'm still
riding a horse why don't we will get it
to that right there that's crazy but
what I will say oh that was a good one
kid that I remember we copped ours in
the same yes your doubts we're getting
switched with an event at that point so
that definitely did what's up Sarah what
you got man your person what's up oh of
course we're going don't make right the
reason it's so good to me personally is
because at the end of the day when you
get down to the brass tacks a game and
you do it to have fun and this
generation in the last while I've never
had so much fun playing a game
legitimately and it barely comes down to
the gameplay that's the thing about it
like it has a good story and everything
else is good it even has some beats
where it you know it has a hiccup bit
and it
not too great but the gameplays oh man
sorry I like though what was what's he
talking about
Oh another cab car get how coincidence
don't you total gonna be a lot of love I
know like that we may cry the gameplay
in that game is so developers and
publishers right the gameplay in that is
so good whether you're sitting there
you're you're doing like you're 50 60
hit combo and you're sitting there going
from your Beowulf and boxing with some
demons the switch to you switch to your
Michael Jackson no it's different man
you need to stop that game is so fluid
and you got the music in the background
why like when you're playing as nothing
you got subhuman blast in the background
and everything you got your your
voiceover style like this is like the
God of War of Devil May cry's okay I did
and I compared it and entered that will
make cry 3 and that was something I
genuinely never thought I would do
because that will make ride 3 has always
been my all-time favorite action game
unquestionably mmm because I think as
far as action game goes gameplay wise
that'll make cry 3 is perfect and every
way and I don't think that will make our
I 5 passes it but it's up there it gives
it it gives a competition so I would
have a two-part question it says just
this Jen or is it like just this year of
the decade of the decade
this is your personal time this is my
first song well
like you they probably expect me to say
the division race but it's actually
probably not that I actually for I think
it's time PD it for a lot hold on I got
my reasons now I'm one of those types of
people that love to play games with
other people and why Mirian
one of the experiences that I have had
so much fun with with my family is
actually playing over cooked believe it
or not because I can't tell you how fun
it is to sit I try to get stream that
with me but you wouldn't play oh my god
playing with my wife playing it with my
brother my sister or my niece and my
wife together I'm telling you the
Anarchy that happens and there's the
amount of fun and laughter smacking your
brother in the head with a pizza pie
it's just like I just I can't tell you
how much I enjoyed having that time with
those with them so who's really good
shot to Brad with two hours of chat love
he's a Grimm zero love Democrat but
everybody cry 5 gameplay
all right I gotta go this is my in the
corner vote that nobody care about but I
gotta ride a guy I should know based on
how I arrived for this stupid little
game but this is for - yeah - tried to
throw next comp to him to wait on it and
it just didn't it was not fully fleshed
out but part one it had two actor from
Duke Nukem or whatever it has some of
the best writing the best people man and
to try to do an X competition at all
well it all bro that little get it is
the most controversial sensational we
don't care about morals and feelings and
political correctness it is everything
in this game you know saying like
corruptness dealing with the Mafia
trying to be a crooked Commissioner
trying to be on it you had so many
things that could injure gameplay
session
hey you have to manage and trying to be
a just Commissioner with the mob on you
like it what's up with these payments
every week for him or were you you think
it's a game okay
is it a cinema what just happened he
could be like oh man
hey the game didn't give you any clues
and then like just funny stuff like
you'd have all these cops and you sent
him to work and you're doing you good
sending him on assignments and stuff and
dudes be like you're I drank last night
and I ain't coming into work family what
you mean I'm not coming into a place
like this crazy into that gate weapon
studios man that was a treasure I was
happy I got a sequel love the game to
writing his fantastic the cinematic the
voice acting one oh and I'm surprised
was actually gonna switch based on how
much sure was well salute this the
police that's my little in the corner
jump off we bring them right back around
to edit what you got
so this is just this generation yes yes
I'd have to say destiny because you
already used it for another forum but I
mean that that's influential that
influenced it's it's it's like I was
gonna say how disappointed I was of
Kingdom Hearts 3 but we ain't gonna go
into that but uh you know like destiny
wanted to you know it was it was some of
the best gaming I've done this
generation if not the best gaming I've
done this generation like I can't really
replicate the feeling of like walking up
to orcs and he's popping up out of the
raid for the first time well were you
know like seeing K die for the first
time like you know you can't really
replicate that solve or sinister telling
me he needs help
yes I gotta go with the Last of Us
batting with the last note like that
that game was the swan song for the ps3
and the ps3 you know for both I think
that game single-handedly delivered them
this gen because they they ended the gym
they ended the gin will probably one of
the best games ever made ever made and
it for me
just
the story in that game and what I care
about most in naughty dog games is the
relationships between the characters how
well yes is usually like this the
setting and the overarching story isn't
great I've never been a fan of the
overarching stories in like the
Uncharted games this was one where I hid
everything like the characters the
stories behind the characters the
overarching story and actually the game
for the game play could be wonky but
there's something about you know when
you pick up a brick into somebody's face
in that game it feels like it really
really yeah exactly it's that feeling
like wow I've never felt this in a game
like the cola vibrates and it's you feel
like you have to survive in a way that I
never felt honestly man honestly like I
can't wait to see what they do a part
two because to me it's it's that level
of immersion like how do you create a
world that feels real when you're
playing it and especially now in a game
that's like last of us which is very
narrative ly focused it's you know it's
not an open-world so I'm excited for it
man but the Last of Us really it was
amazing okay decade personal Halo Wars
really this kind of mistake here was
that that real-time strategy competitive
is usually done on PC and I didn't think
they was ever gonna bring it over and
it's gonna work properly
and when I got the feel of it with the
controller
me an addict was over the moon on this
because he was like yo did you get a
chance to did you download it and then
they further along this story I really
thought that it captured the essence of
Halo with bringing you more characters
and getting you more immersed into one
of those dudes off and get novels yeah I
go front when addict put me on to the hg
Ark yes that dude at a triage name
yeah that showed me something i think i
think they there's never been a way of
introducing a villain quite like a trio
that's like what she was like who did
that she's like his name is a tree ox
boy wait he did it because literally put
like a bad vibe down your spine like
this dude's gonna kill me yeah like you
use terrified like well it's like you
know yes Spartan wars going into it and
you know if furthered along the halo
story I'm a little dude and anywhere I
can get those little nuggets but I'm
picking up one of these stupid little
girl okay give me your audiobook I'm
driving I don't want to sit there
reading in the corner you know the pink
is riding with you Rose I'm back I mean
in halo halo wars 2 is definitely better
than Halo 5 story and yeah I think the
only reason if halo if halos infinite
it's story wise is saved is because of
the introduction of Halo Wars 2 story
this is strong man I gotta give the
Attic on this and got King I've shut
that strong man that's just wrong I like
that zero what you got there I'm gonna
bring up a name y'all probably I heard
in a while
I'm probably gonna get flack from AJ
about this
I'm gonna say arc and the reason I'm
gonna say arc is because I had a world
of issues I'm why I had a world of
issues that I had never right and I had
I have never debated the fact that it
had a head all kinds of problems it was
a technical mess because as much as I
love destiny asked for games that power
right as much as I but I love that
saying everything no only getting game
at the time they could take me away from
destiny was arc
and it did it on a regular basis because
that that game was like a drug and I
don't know why but it was to be fair
Fonz I'd rather play art and read that
[Music]
immediately on art and then I'll glitch
to the map immediately the reason why I
like art because it was it was an ark
stories not nothing to gain playing
there that stuff oh when I played it was
like a picture movie or whatever but
slashing it yo when eight so when he
snatched up fat boy and it took him on a
boat you know drop addict from the show
down I won't say this as much as I I
lost a bet to dizzy tried to play that
damn game I despised like he had to show
mercy to me he was like argh I see the
disgust in you it was like i'ma let you
offer your prison sentence for playing
this game hearing your stories about
that game and what you I do to other
tribe I can't front yard is to be
telling me like beef be happening if you
listen if you listen to this tell
stories for a half an hour my god you
will feel a it's a lifetime that that
man is lived
history I was listening to y'all is
crazy let me get up Feeny bit come on
down what's the personal let's go
um I I really loved children amorta like
that game we we ended up getting some
time on it we'll unpack CST's now maybe
I did a couple years before and then I
got to review it and I just got sucked
in it has this amazing story it has this
amazing um you know type of system with
the communicate the story I like every
time you died there was a different
story
every single time you were able to
complete a level it was a different
story it never felt the same and I it it
was done really really well and it was a
really really good game the game that
came out like right before the decade
[Music]
about that thing I don't know about them
Rex
ashley is the difference between play
and mass effect though and layin
different decisions hold and wait the
renegade a paragon system you're like
Commander Shepard the Citadel man it is
such an influence you getting to was the
pinnacle because remember part one has
the rough outline had the great story
right cinematics we had Saren come in it
was told but you elevator sequences they
had to make ol but it was a little rough
graphically moving around to refine that
combat that's when you had your
engineering spill you send your little
drone out you had your bionics you pull
somebody away like you can play so many
different ways and then to also let's
keep it keep it above the moat I play
people don't be sweetly sleeping on a
multiplayer yeah
yes Mass Effect's multi-player was shout
the other Zig dealmaker for really let's
get with my Mass Effect dude let's talk
about it like Mass Effect will never
like it's one you can say which is one
about three and how and they mean but
I've never seen a series systematically
go from one part to the second to the
third and the decisions or I think that
was one of the first games to do it
right now and the characters you be like
damn I lost Rex you don't say he died
and they did it carried over them dudes
who's dead the next game that is one
thing for sure like Bioware at their
prime I don't think no one could touch
you know I remember play Dragon Age
Inquisition and like just having a
casual conversation and then it just
goes from yeah we're good to like two of
my people were trying to kill me
oh I've seen her the whole time fighting
them cuz I had a rule I didn't I didn't
play back nothing they just dead and I
was sitting there fighting fighting this
chick it was in a majors tower and she
and it went from we good so she's trying
to kill me and I killed her and I'm like
I'm just think I'm so how did we get
here look shelter gave me Forte files
which I Happy Holidays to my favorite
part thank you brother
destiny is my game with a decade no game
pissed me off more yo eyes well finish
up a bass effect love 8,000 Wow Wow how
they want extra what's funny I love Matt
for me what got me into mass effect from
the beginning part one I didn't play
part one when it came out and then when
I when I heard the name of the villain I
was a hold up I won't be honest I got I
would really like a weird rabbit hole
planet mining some bars I know use a
massive a give me some bar 0 the one the
one thing that no like people mention
something that people barely mentioned
oh all the flavor something that doesn't
really get talked about a lot that Mass
Effect did is one of the DLCs they put
out I believe it was for Mass Effect 3
and it was the one where literally the
whole point of this DLC was to party
with your buds in the game and I loved
that so much because the love scenes
with the oh no we're doing boot up I
would have to say the Kingdom Hearts
series because I can't really think of
any right off the bat because you guys
took a lot of them but like I remember
like one of my closest friends like he
let me borrow Kingdom Hearts to when I
was in high school and like I remember
thinking like it was literally
joking inside joke of all my friends
every time we break in more stories
coming out this year it's gonna come out
at e3 this year no one really thought
this game was ever gonna come out o
[Laughter]
[Music]
malley our was my girl I had a go flea
arm and I mean she actually had those
lips let's stop the mass effect on I um
you guys know I love my stealth games so
I have to go with mark of the ninja oh
that is good yeah 2d Xbox Live Arcade
game that came out in 2012
oh this on this little 2d game I you
know I love the essence of the ninja
Todd knows that like anything happened
to do with ninja is like tension tension
back in the day obviously mocking the
ninja Metal Gear and of course Splinter
Cell the ninja did what a lot of these
games don't do is that it really gave
you the choice of how to play like you
really had to play like an engine you
can murder people if you wanted or you
could get through utilizing your tools
without being seen at all and the way
that they utilize line-of-sight and
eliminating light sources so that you
could have more hiding places in
addition to all the way that you all the
ways you can murder characters in that
game and and the story was itself was
cool as well besides the gameplay
mechanics was fantastic but the story
was this sort of old ninja clan fighting
and like like the changing of the tide
and like modernization and and tech
Aladin and fighting against that you
know this game absolutely blew me away I
finished every I think I you know I got
the 4000 points game points in this game
it was an absolutely amazing game one of
the best stealth games of all time did
you get did you get the remastered
version of it yes I did actually we have
one more don't we're on the last storm
zone yes I have one more because I
artists from okay I'm gonna have to sing
my game with a decade watch what just
get striked over that actually chant
that's right but yeah spider-man when I
first saw no white why you think of this
we all know because when I first started
trill acid is an absolutely no way
inhaling I made that and then when I saw
the game it to me hands-down
won this generation that game I mean I
don't even know how God a war even won
any awards
but I just want to say the level of
first of all the DLC own the most mature
spider-man game that has ever been when
spider-man is an illegitimate daddy
oh we think the fluidity the the the
amount of suits the the amount of
collectible stuff that it was so much
fun it was fun
yeah it was really fun and it made you
feel like a superhero I went to the
tallest building I took pictures I drove
off but it was it's my game of this
generation in a decade or so our dad
wave again
those l0 I'm gonna have to go to a
franchise that PD mentioned earlier and
mention a specific game and that's gonna
be dark souls 3 Dark Souls has always
been something near and dear to me ever
since I played it it's the first game
series that I played that literally made
me want to rage and quit but I love the
game so much because it forces you to
learn and get better because it's a game
that's not gonna hold your hand and the
thing that sets Dark Souls through your
part for me is a story and lore inside
of it because it's everything is so rich
and deep and it asks you to actually
want to be interested and learn about it
it's it's not something that force-feed
you that kind of thing if you want to
play the game so G deep it's real deep
yeah it's actually deep fry and it makes
sense it's actually a probably a game
most people have not heard of but I've
been actually playing it pretty hard
that's of late this game called escape
from tarkov it is probably the most
realistic first-person shooter I have
ever played and when I started playing
it I was getting destroyed and I have
been playing for about 55 days and I've
already put in almost 400 hours into it
out are you getting the paddles that's
what paddle that's what is so realistic
it's it's so great I love it to death
and I I think that it's got so much
potential because it's still technically
in its beta phase but it's every single
time they add more of a patch to it
they're adding more and more and more
and eventually it's gonna get you know
storyline and all that other stuff but
playing it now and seeing how it's
growing it's amazing I think it's going
to be huge
I love it my last one is probably gonna
be a little cheek because it's kind of
two years but it's actually taking in
mortal combat like
yes yes I mean we remember mortal combat
from one you know saying like just see
how it changed then they went through
that dead Lowell period I would say
after five maybe five or six it kind of
was trying to find herself it was in a
weird space it went 3d it wasn't it just
never hit but when MK 9 came out and
they rebooted and did the timeline joint
from didn't they set the ball with
cinematic storytelling in your fighting
game Mortal Kombat's one of the very few
games I know that they're like we don't
care what scanning because we could
change this in the next game they make
what what you want a mini combat is
something like to see what it's done in
nether realm and those guys tremendous
like I play that story I want to know
what happened really like you wanna know
you know I'm saying like that joint
it's just revolution it so sheltered I'm
doing and of course like I said I'm
cheating this is two games but like yo I
never forget but we was at that III and
Akuma came into the game and they was
like he is cannon retribution or taking
out some of the craziest stuff going on
with a family tree throwing kids off
valcano
burning some very father dad bad
relationship series game so this scene
Kazu joint relationship they've always
got the new characters but to see that
engine to see Unreal Engine to see it
come out on the market off stage and see
how her rotting them really took that
much only thing Hirata yeah this
disrespectfully I did not do no Xbox
enhancements to that game that's very
different for in still in 720 Peters no
excuse that the PlayStation regular is
doing it better than that but that's
another story but anyway Tekken Tekken 7
Mortal Kombat man they train keeps going
and it's not stopping it's just amazing
to see that those two have remained
relevant you know I'm saying and
dominate like I still people Evo in all
that so salute to them to man those are
the oh geez still going strong
- have you got anything up before you
know I wanted like an all real mention
it's like Dishonored
I really enjoyed those two games yes
yeah I mean those games the stealth
mechanics sort of immersive sim
mechanics where you could approach the
world in a number of different ways the
powers it's a little bit it's a little
bit of beef a little bit of Bioshock
it's a system shock like it's wow those
games really are special and I have the
achievement killing nobody in the whole
game
that's not an easy thing to do no you
can kill somebody Mama's thing I'm gonna
know how many times you reset let's go
okay
dead cells know that introduce me in the
areas bad because that's one game and I
got you that good like that no that's
one of the games that I will jump in the
shower or take a shower and say and I'm
calculating how many games that I can
get in before it's time to sleep mm-hmm
and I get up and I'm jumping on it and
they're playing like they're doing
destiny so well let me know when y'all
about to do the nightfall because I'm
gonna do this this part of it then I'll
mute myself it's a bit the game I
started playing it all over wherever I
can just you know play the X cloud thank
God it introduced me to what a roguelike
game was I didn't understand what that
meant like motivating about this game
like a shut up was a sovereign soundly
knows our taste in games so like many
recommend some we could joke around a
play around I take all the ways out your
guys's taste right you know listen red
can say whatever I still purchased the
game I purchased at their strenght I
could tell you that um because I take
his recommendations but this game was so
well done and I'm
when your sword at PAX and y'all made a
beeline to it because it was one of the
games that was on our list and yeah I
made a beeline to it nails like yeah it
has to get I was like what's this little
ninja crap game and it's not it's way
more than that and when I sword in-game
past I said let me give it a shot
shout out to Phil Dominus manage my
account pad for allowing me to play a
game that I would have never purchased I
would have never thought about buying
and I fell in love with and now if it
occurs from that game pad they make it
that's dead cells - you have a good
chance of buying that because a game
pass yes I got too much sub game pass
just release some stuff god bless its
katana zero and get past your door now
no I just downloaded um but that's
really good sir earth not earth for
what's the game that we played sovereign
we did the interview for it and you had
to go and yet they extract the souls out
of right remember the world is desolate
and you had to fight the creatures and
it was a big game to man when we did the
interview that was a good interview that
you did - can I just because it started
in New York and that's just what it was
that's knowingness in New York you know
just when students started in New York
and the progression and seeing how
realistic it was to the real life it
kind of just that's what I loved from it
I feel like we need we need we need to
call calm PD app how is that you play
this game 24/7 and now you mentioned the
division yeah that and I just it's
personal almost of eternity is out
in-game past for the final topic since
we got our choice off so this was fun I
like this one by attic this was a little
different like a
Oh P 2019 in review you don't see a lot
of things that happen or eminent sorry
over ebony there we go a lot of will be
able to see your favorite either moments
that happen on IOP or episodes or gassed
or funny things just something from ILP
so Eddie died Z pretty much anything was
switched off again I really enjoyed the
list war the way we the one that you
want and I had to do the apology Lou
yeah go on
I remember what they should spit so many
this year why this is crazy
that's all I can think about the top of
my own alright soft wait I see I know
okay no there's one more I could think
up wouldn't be in a when me King did
that commercial I saw some people in
that chat say that that was planned that
was not playing oh honey would favor
everything is just like such a big blur
man like it's so much I gotta say
everything we did it at e3 this year
this year we were out there like this on
and around we were able to do you know
first time we were kind of all day all
of us were there we were able to
actually do like reactions to things and
in a way that people expect from us so
for me it was that it was just the fact
that at this year's e3 we will all and
we were able to get into pretty much
everything in some way shape or form
okay yeah that was it for me
I got a whole bunch of nice ones I can I
don't want to pick a guess over another
guess because I have so much fun with
all the guests pause what I would say is
this I would say and a play crafting and
PlaNYC I think that was a great eye
opening experience that New York has a
homegrown thing and shout out the damn
bush going Skyward Sword
yo mention the one that's how that
that's how that case look too that's why
you look that the case is fire the game
what I don't have a favorite moment so
much as I have a favorite episode that I
always look forward to in it that is the
one right after a three because
everybody comes over here and I mean
normally everybody's passionate about
what they're talking about so it makes
the podcast so original but that Dame
and everybody is so fired up and they're
so caught up on what they want to bond
even what they think every year every
year that's some of our highest viewed
podcasts too because that's that's when
the real love of gaming the industry
everything comes together and like I
said there's arguments there's
disagreements there's heated moments and
whatnot but at the end of the day it's
all for fun and it's always the year
before last wasn't it like four hours
long I got I got two I love to do what
one was us at us in PAX East like I
can't tell you how much passion and
energy I felt from the team going to
there with the guys and wanting to push
through and it makes me so excited to go
this upcoming year with with everyone
because it was just it was so intense
and so great and I just I can't wait to
see everybody and hang out and you know
dude to that and the other thing was
having all of the interviews with all of
the you know all of our developers and
all of our you know all of our other you
know podcasts friends and and all other
wars and everything and hearing
everybody's stories it's just it's
amazing to hear everything from
everybody and I just I can't tell you
how much I love that you cannot that
that time of hearing everybody so I
can't I can't say that you know I was
gonna say do it like working with you
guys and doing everything and hearing
everyone's stories it wouldn't be
without them for us being here so I love
them more than anything
[Music]
ready three was a girl rebellion studio
solvent attic we had that one which go
king that was so many good ones and did
funny like yes like it's hard to pick
out specific it cuz I remember so many
moments I mean we could good games good
with a with a dumb nobody take a girl
was a funny way spilling at tea or my
personal favorite though I go for it
like one of my fav
I can't pick up you know say but one of
my personal favorite was definitely we
did do the Xbox Bob episode I got crazy
for the shinebox I'll be always dying
bro like I just getting into it that's
always a classic you know sale even the
so DJ BG up a fight with Kerry kid
Gordon that was a funny one cuz member
was silver sky you are and they'll try
to go against destiny
he's older we don't had that when BG was
like preach it revin the Destiny speech
that he's trying to go in and I said
that's not good sorry I can't pick I
can't pick again a quick play play craft
and I was just home and ambushed going
to just ask ourself for fun but um I
can't pick a guess because every guess
is a gym and when Stephen was on and his
white suit on so I can't pick a guess
because every guest like y'all guys
probably think that all we plan out
stuff and we know this is completely
100% organic this is none of it we
weirdest grip up and everybody got a
follow a lineman on I'm in enough that's
not how it goes and the whole thing is
like when you come into my household and
how come you will give you a glass of
water you want something to drink sit
down we talk that's what this is ya know
so we talking to you guys yeah we
interacting with you because you're in
our house we're here together this is
the Rope layer together so I'm a little
respite people asks how can we do for I
was on a podcast because it doesn't feel
like wow we having fun right shout out
to dizzy favorite moment 2019 launching
of Lourdes and gaming net best movement
period shout out to my riders putting in
that work frost for holding the epic
position down you know and then on a pot
like I gotta put it out there like wanna
I got a shout out like the wrong yo cuz
like we went to a lot you know I'm sad
end of the day you know like I said loss
whiskey then we had you know kick dizzy
going through it you know I'm saying and
to see everyone rally for the foot you
know I'm saying for the crest for the
[ __ ] like no I'm sorry I don't want this
for any other I just feel like our base
I'm so proud to be a part of it don't
say that people really come and just
really rock with us and you know have so
much fun and you know I actually think I
am the most proud of the old king is
that
you know what I'm about to say too is
that I love the fact that we may have
people on ILP that may not necessarily
get along with each other but it's like
you come into the room you put your
weapons down
we gonna have a respect everybody's
gonna have fun you know say and people
that may not have gotten wrong to come
in here and they know the type of
environment we're gonna bring and that
to me it's like I'm super proud of that
you know I'm saying like a few I think
that's doing that but yeah that's what I
got like we got a lot of things poppin
my shopping was a game with that net you
know sack I said did he say birth doubt
here but else you guys saw a ghost wanna
shout out know me honestly just couldn't
like it just to reiterate what you guys
said honestly the growth that we've seen
with Lords of gaming done net and
podcast over the past year it's kind of
crazy man and you know I we've said this
before but Cox passion is kind of
unsurpassed like GOG had a vision for
this and he does not let up like hey you
can you hear you can see cog at all
hours of the night on discord and and
like just editing little uh articles
that are going up or just answering
questions that people might have like
ACOG is always on the go I don't know
how often he sleeps you know all we do I
look the first thing I go on Twitter and
I click that that that mentions tab I'm
like oh he he he replied it someone two
minutes ago he's up and it's like he
replied seven hours oh no he's asleep
okay what I gotta hit him up I first
checked this cord I'm like is your
active is you not active and then after
that I'm like is it after one o'clock
I'm not calling my different spots they
look at look format like I'm a messenger
it tells me how many I always he was
over okay he sleep
but it is love man at the end of the day
is like he's just a team I'm just proud
like all you guys like everybody that
come and do this thing every week and I
kick said I don't even feel like a job
and didn't again I can't stress enough
floors he gave me that bro like
grassroot baby you know I'm saying and
just seeing people come together that I
mean just tremendous
you know shout the frost dizzy undead I
mean the knit list goes on mods gaming
you know I'm saying like so many people
that are just willing to come together
and do try to do some specialty I cannot
be more appreciative of fun you know
what it is is it's not really sighs as
the substance yeah like you know this
when when you hit me up before one day
you're like he's a little erratic or no
you okay everything's good and I'm like
that's what I'm talking about like i KMS
from people that I kill everything is
good or you know I'm I need a question
for this I love when somebody hits me up
with business questions I'm trying to do
this how's this gonna go do you have any
advice with this or we're talking food
we're talking is it's different like we
have so many different personalities and
aspects of individuals that are that are
in the chair you say hey what as far as
found 100% yes what if I don't how many
I was we've been in here but I've been
rocking and killing me with Christopher
Hart has become boomstick excels the you
know say like these are people that we
look forward to seeing that neighbor the
boss moves the Jonathan B's that like
it's certain I get excited always about
to be or even the episode we had but we
had co-ed Oh in what you call it far as
all together you know involved to read
daddy next
[Laughter]
but yo I just want to say that I take
you to the realm you know I'm saying
everybody to still be gonna close out
swing 19 of vibes is late 2020 but to be
big we're going hot we go to comedy
thank you guys for rocky waters very
really really appreciated it the support
is tremendous Adam let you get off some
stuff you want to get on before you go
know that yeah I'm cool I'm ready to go
our Star Wars comeback now I just want
to say Happy Holidays happy holidays to
everyone happy New Year to everyone have
a happy and safe with your family I love
you I know that lordy lordy I appeal in
xbox if you want to hang out mostly
playing destiny and whatnot right now I
just really wanted to get in today
because I think it's been like a year or
more because I've been on and I get
swapped now now that a completely right
yeah
it speaks to um it speaks to the
attitude and the feeling of the podcast
though because what it's been so long
since I've been on and when I was
getting on today you know there wasn't
any hesitation in any pocket brother
right any nervous that's because this
like King said this is family this is
coming into a house hanging out with
your brothers and knowing and
everything's gonna be fine and I mean
we've had to addict literally maybe walk
off that podcast one day but the thing
is after we finished that podcast and
they we sat down and we you know we
hashed it out in like what
minutes and we were cool after that
because that's what brothers do I mean
that's the his family so I appreciate
being back home and I miss y'all thank
now but you dude I'm glad you came and I
was still PD just weren't just you know
just where to find me everyone knows
it's now though on everything Twitter to
twitch
you know the discord everything but I
just wanted to say thanks to everybody
on the panel for you know I'm doin
everything this year and all the chances
that we've had and you know giving us
the opportunity to put a post the stream
team podcast here also with everybody
and we got some really amazing guests
coming up next year we've already
booking people so it's it's it's gonna
be like I said it's gonna be hot for
everybody and we're gonna be we're gonna
be good and I just wanted to say you
know everybody else have a fantastic
fantastic holiday and you know see you
guys you know what you can definitely
find me is here at 1:00 p.m. thank you
you know what you won't find me is me
here at 11:00 a.m. starting next year
you can find me at a Twitter and I Lord
at its IOP you can find me on youtube at
gaming addict and you know you can find
me at the movies in about an hour and go
watching the Star Wars so I could come
home and complain in the book the single
place you're gonna find said 2020 on
Twitter and on PSN Xbox Live guys we're
11 months away from a new console
generation wow that crazy grill floor
I got too much gaming in between it a
word but that's right pass is coming
with us
I'm bringing all my stuff no game left
behind that was it man yeah crazy it's
crazy no stop winning crown your Lords
our works I work so much I like all
podcasts I listen to like all of our
YouTube brothers brother in addition to
like all like the big sites right so I
respect this from everywhere so when
people like hear disco Elysium a lot of
people like one category thank you
brother another great show great way to
close out the year
I can't wait for 2020 because gaming is
gonna be fire have a safe and joyful
holiday so look focus cream King another
one in for the King to premature the
Lord of the catchphrases the Lord of the
stage Lord of everyone's favorite
t-shirts and it's slang out here moving
the Dominus 'as the who did that for you
moving out here wicked a fire here be
gone but King the statues oh we got
another one in here baby you got more
coming
I got like what I got like 50 statues
right you know like so come yes right
right right yes yes yes I pay the money
and yoga just posted all right please
come on okay y'all catch me on a io p
youtube channel you can catch me at laws
again with that net we just can you see
almost ninja turtle come on man you know
about their who they definitely
all they're all for I even make you
suffer you know five weeks of giving you
one turtle one toad or one turtle in a
team no I give you all in one delicious
package oh shout out shout out to color
[Laughter]
shout out the game abide choice with the
$20 super chat great snowing thank you
for a wonderful 2019 and looking forward
to 2020 happy holidays same to you yes
thank you also combat talk with the king
that is up there and listen Twitter see
what was what kognito tells me is good
you know look at this show notes and
look and look at on the comments they
put down in in to act with them the
reason why I yelling over here me
interacting with you guys is because I'm
accessible like you see me a king OTW
on Xbox jump on our Xbox we can play you
know you see me on Twitter tweet me we
can tweet we can you know so if I got a
chance to read some of the comments and
is one guy I was in there and he says
something that's why don't we Thomas
because he said something that wasn't
factual he said you know we'll call ya
he said we were we were corporate shills
don't be me and it was a you know Duvall
they've devolved into like a fanboy
thing
alright listen at the at the end of the
day we all fanboys we wouldn't be here
right um but we know where we started
like you may think okay well you know
King started with Xbox man shut your
mouth like I started with ColecoVision I
started way back before you was even a
thought in your father cells down yeah
so but also at the same time I was
PlayStation before you was able to
purchase a disc and I was riding for
them against Nintendo and everybody else
I was I was capping for them
this is the same cap that you see me
doing for Microsoft because they don't
undergo --g I was capping for the
accident champions cog could tell you we
slept in front of stores for these
systems we live for this stuff um but
it's not in particular it's not one
console that defines a person or defines
yet generation how you play it's where
you game and how you gain you understand
you can game anywhere and when I'm
talking about Wii U game you gave me
your living room you gave me a bathroom
where are you game and how you games not
what you game on that doesn't define you
so what you have to understand is you
have to go out there financially maybe
right now is a little tough situation
for yourself you have to come to a
realization with yourself because you
look at yourself in the mirror and say
why am i hating on xbox so much or why
am i hating on this it's a fear of
jumping into another ecosystem because
financially you can't carry that but
what you want to do is 2020 is coming
you know you pray you get your energy
together for the winter solstice going
into forward right and what you do is
you put those man-hours in so you can
game harder and better next year and you
don't turn into that fanboy that you
claim that one of us were because we all
cap for games so I just told you my game
at a decade is spider-man find yourself
[Laughter]
but you look very proud of y'all up save
it's very very audited my attendance
record is impeccable listen to me this
is why they may be
you wanted to call me but my mom my
tendons dope oh yeah my brother's man
and I love doing this podcast it's
always a pleasure I make it easy to make
my life easier
sound the Lords of gaming neck all the
team man all y'all is gonna be crazy
2020 look out for really big digs
happy holidays all that good stuff Happy
New Year January 5th
I believe we come back 1 p.m. if you're
a small forehead a real software head
hit me up in the dam's I got something
cooking no doubt 1 p.m. that's what we
got everybody enjoy see you guys next
year we are out of here
pigs